[Zene]
sziasztok ez egy rendhagyó epizód ahol
nem lesz vendégem akit meghívok akivel
beszélgessek és ebbe az epizódbaan arról
fogunk beszélgetni hogy a különböző ai
chatbotokat mint például a chat gpt-t
hogyan lehet használni hogyan tudjuk
arra használni hogy a produktivitásunk
megnőjön ezelőtt két évvel amikor
elindultak ezek a chatbotok többek
között a a chat gpt amikor amikor kijött
akkor az első é z éem emlékszem a
félelem volt attól féltem hogy mint
programozó hogyha tud programkódot írni
akkor lehet hogy el fogom veszíteni a
munkámat és hogy egyre inkább el fogjuk
veszíteni a munkánkat ahogy az idő telik
és bizonyos szempontból ami azóta
történt az ráerősítette erre a
félelmemre különböző ai modellek egyre
potensebbek arra hogy programkódokat
írjunk viszont én nem akartam félni azt
akartam hogy hogy megismerjem akkor a
ezt az ai chatbotot ez egy alapelv is
amúgy hogy ha valamitől félünk a legjobb
az hogyha önként vállalva szembenézünk
ezzel a félelemmel úgyhogy elkezdtem
intenzíven tanulmányozni hogy hogyan
lehet ezt produktivitásra használni
hogyan tudok egy jobb menedzserré válni
hogyan tudok egy jobb cégvezetővé válni
hogyan tudok egy jobb családapává is
válni akár azáltal hogy ezt az ai
chatbotot használom ami például a a chat
gpt is a célom az hogy olyan alapokat
tudjak megosztani olyan kincseket amik
amelyeket szinte nap mint nap használok
másokkal is amelyek általános érvényűek
amelyeket nem csak a chat gpt-nél lehet
használni hanem a geminiinenál grocknál
és más hasonló chatbotoknál is lehet
használni én azt tapasztaltam
személyesen hogy körülbelül legalább
háromszor produktívabbá váltam a a a
szakmai életemben és nem csak a szakmai
életemben bizonyos szempontból ez nem
egy túlzás mint székely nem szeretem az
ilyen hangzatos csilvili amerikai
címeket hogy hogyan fogyjunk le 30 nap
alatt hogyan legyünk gazdagok 10
lépésből egyszerűen anélkül hogy
energiát fektessünk bele mégis ezt a
címet választottam ennek a videónak mert
azt látom hogy minimum háromszor
produktívabb lett az én életem bizonyos
területeken több mint háromszor akár
tíszer is például egy jogi dokumentum
esetében amit ha én kéne megfogalmazzak
és én kéne átnézzek lefordítsak ez
napokat talán heteket venne igénybe
hogyha jól meg kellene csinálni de mivel
nem vagyok jogász nagyon sok időt kell
eltöltsek és nincs rászokva a szemem
arra hogy hogyan olvassak egy jog jogi
dokumentumot úgyhogy ilyen szempontból
több mint tíszeres lett a a ezen a téren
a hatékonyságnövekedésem de úgy
általában azt látom hogy sokkal de
sokkal produktívabbá váltam az életemben
azok az alapelvek amiket itt meg fogok
osztani azok általános érvényűek lehet
használni függetlenül attól hogy milyen
platformot milyen ai modellt szeretünk
nap mint nap hasz használni ugyanúgy
érvényesek mert inkább arra adaptáltam
őket hogy az ember hogyan gondolkozik
mints sem konkrétan magára a
technológiára amit használ a háttérben
egy-két dolog lesz talán ami specifikus
a chat gpt-vel a többi teljesen
általánosan használható ennek a videónak
a célja inkább egy közös gondolkodás a
célom az hogy elmondjam azokat a
számomra nagyon hasznos kincseket amiket
az elmúlt több mint fél év egy év során
megtapasztaltam és magam számára kiástam
és azt szeretném hogy hogy együtt
kezdjünk el közösen gondolkodni akár a
kommenteket írva hogy ti hogyan
használjátok én nagyon kíváncsi vagyok
hogy ti hogyan használjátok a cél az
hogy ne áldozataivá váljunk ennek a a az
ai forradalomnak hanem tanuljuk meg a
saját produktivitásunk érdekében egyre
jobban és egyre céltudatosabban
használni mert a produktivitás
növekedésnek van egy pozitív hozadéka is
az egyik ami számomra pozitív volt az az
hogy több időt tudtam arra szánni ami
számomra fontos például ez a videó sosem
jött volna létre hogyha én mint
menedzser az összes időmet abba fektetem
hogy hogy a különböző csapatoknak a
munkáját koordinálom és zéró idő marad
arra hogy elkezdjek gondolkozni azon
hogy talán ez az oktatási anyag hasznos
lehet más számára is úgyhogy ez az anyag
annak szól aki most ismerkedik a chat
gpt-vel esetleg ugyanaz a félelem ami
bennem is megvolt most esetleg a
hallgatóban is megvan én két
célközönséget lát az egyik az aki még
sosem használta a chat gpt-t és most
ismerkedik vele esetleg ugyanaz a
félelem a hallgatóban is megvan ami
bennem megvolt egy éve és szeretné az
alapokat megismerni hogy hogyan lehetne
használni abba azon a területen ahol
éppen ő dolgozik ez lehet az első
célközönség a második célközönség az
akinek már konkrét tapasztalata van a a
akár a chat gpt-vel akár más ai alapú
chatbottal és szeretné még mélyebben
megismerni pár tippel kiegészíteni
azokat a a módszereket amikkel már amúgy
is dolgozik összességében azt látom hogy
az ai az egy hatalmas lehetőséget is hoz
egyben veszélyt is viszont azáltal hogy
megismerjük és elkezdjük tudni használni
inkább kikerekedik az előny oldala mint
a veszély oldala és azt látom az
egyetlen lehetőség arra hogy jóra tudjuk
használni azt hogyha meg megismerjük ezt
a a az ai adta lehetőséget és nap mint
nap megtanuljuk használni mielőtt
konkrétan a tippekkel kezdünk
foglalkozni hogy hogyan lehet a chat
gpt-t használni szeretnék a
figyelmetekbe ajánlani hat különböző
gondolkodási sémát ahogyan az ember
működik ezeket részletesen majd ki
fogjuk bontani a tippek során is de
szeretném most egyenként megvizsgálni
ezeket az gondolkodási alapokat az első
az az hogy az ember beszélve gondolkozik
a legtöbb ember képtelen arra hogy
igazán komplex dolgokat csak úgy egyedül
kigondoljon gondoljatok csak bele ha
leülnétek és és valamilyen komplex
témáról kezdenétek el gondolkozni akkor
valójában a háttérben az történik hogy a
fejedben különböző érveket kell
szimulálj a különböző mondjam úgy hogy
személyiségeket kell eljátszodj és egy
legyen egy külső nézőpont amelyik
figyeli ezeket az embereket interakció
közben és a lehető legjobb érveket
megérteni és abból levonni egy
következtetést valójában az átlagember
erre képtelen én is egy átlagember
vagyok és nagyon-nagyon nehezemre esik
ez ez a fajta gondolkodás nem hatékony
viszont az átlagember beszélget és a
beszélgetés az egy fajta outsurelt
gondolkodás szimuláljuk a való világban
azt ami a ami egy képzett ember fejében
történik mint egy filozófus vagy
matematikus fejében amikor egy komplex
témáról gondolkozik ilyenkor az történik
hogy a hétköznapi emberek megosztják
egymással a nézőpontjaikat elkezdenek
birkózni egy-egy gondolattal és a
beszélgetés végére mindenki egy picit
jobban megérti azt a a a az adott
témakört amivel éppen birkózik majd
meglátjuk később hogy a tippekben ez
körülbelül úgy fog majd megjelenni hogy
az ai segíteni fog számunkra olyan
vitapartnereket generálni akivel együtt
tudunk gondolkozni beszélgetve és
körbejárva egy témát amely azelőtt
számunkra túl komplex lett volna hogy
egyedül leüljünk és végiggondoljuk a
második gondolkodási alap az az hogy az
ember általában két üzemmódban
gondolkozik az egyik az a a kreatív a
másik pedig a szerkesztői üzemmód most
képzeljünk el egy szöveget amikor
leírunk leülünk és elkezdünk írni egy
szöveget akkor van általában egy kreatív
üzemmód egy jobb agyféltekés üzemmód
amikor csak úgy jönnek a gondolatok egy
flowban egyszerűen szinten magától
erőltetésmentesen le tudjuk írni a
gondolatainkat és hogyha ilyenkor nem
figyelünk akkor
áthetünk a szerkesztő üzemmódba ez egy
bal agyféltekés feladat amikor
struktúálunk hely írást javítunk
egymáshoz képest logikai sorrendet
állítunk fel az van hogy ha egymás után
sokszor a flowból meg kiesünk nagyon
nehéz visszakerülni ebben is segíteni
tud számunkra a chat gpt sőt ez talán az
egyik legnagyobb hozadéka ugyanis
képesek vagyunk ezt a flowban eltöltött
időpont időszakot kinyújtani és csak
később foglalkozni azzal hogy
szerkesszük a szöveget a harmadik
gondolkodási alapja az embernek az az
hogy a tanulás folyamán
általában úgy ahogy a gráfelméletben van
egy szélességi és mélységi bejárás úgy
maga a tananyag megismerése is lehet
szélességi és mélységi hogyha most
veszünk egy könyvet és elolvassuk magát
a tartalomjegyzéket az egy szélességi
bejárásnak felel meg amikor egy
általános képet kapunk magáról a
tananyagról amikor viszont elkezdjük
olvasni sorról sorra a a tananyagnak a
szövegét akkor általában mélységi
bejárást alkalmazunk amikor az
információ mélyére próbálunk hat tolni
ebben is segíteni fog számunkra a chat
gpt ugyanis olyan tananyagokat tudunk
generáltatni amelyek specifikusan
szélességi átfogó tudást de felületes
tudást eredményeznek és amikor szükséges
a mélységeikben meg tudjuk ismerni magát
az anyagot a negyedik téma amit fel
szeretnék dobni az a mindmap módszer a
mindmap módszer az egy vizuális
ábrázolása komplex témaköröknek egy
komplex témát körbevesznek bizonyos
fogalmak és a a fogalmaknak az egymáshoz
képest vett relációi általában hogyha
vizuálisan látjuk sokkal könnyebben
maradnak meg nekünk ebben is segíteni
fog tudni nekünk a chat gpt hogy egy
olyan témakört ami számunkra túl komplex
megtanuljunk lebontani és egy mindmap
módszer segítségével mélyebben megérteni
az ötödik gondolkodási alap az a
különböző nézőpontoknak és az érvelési
technikáknak a a megközelítése ahhoz
hogy egy komplex témát meg tudjunk
érteni több nézőpontból ahhoz szükségünk
van arra hogy a különböző nézőpontoknak
mélységeiben ismerjük az álláspontjait
de mi emberekként szubjektív nézőponttal
rendelkezünk ha mélységesen meg vagyunk
győződve valamiről nagyon nehéz az
ellenkezőjét képviseljük ebben is segít
számunkra a chat gpt és ezt is ezt mint
eszköz fel fogjuk használni majd a
következő néhány tippnél bocsánat az
utolsó módszer amit szeretnék javasolni
az az hogy az ember sokkal könnyebben
ért meg komplexebb folyamatokat hogyha
kap egy analógiát vagy egy metaforát rá
tehát ha elkezdünk egy könyvet olvasni
és benne egy szakkönyvet tegyük fel egy
komplex mechanizmusról ami úgy nem
nagyon ugrik be nekünk nem nagyon értjük
hogy miről szól de azt mondja tegyük fel
valaki hogy ó ez egyszerű ez pont úgy
működik mint egy postai rendszer ahol a
levelet bedobják egy postaládába majd
naponta kétszer egy postás arra jár és
az összes levelet ami addig be volt oda
doobva azt összegyűjtés egy központi
raktárba viszi akkor egyből beírt be
beugrik számunkra hogy ahá szóval erről
van szó és ahányszor utána erről a a
komplex témakörről kezdünk el
gondolkozni már tudjuk valójában hogy
hogyan asszociálódik hogyan hogyan
függenek egymástól ezek a a gondolatok
ebben is segíthet számunkra a chat gpt
hogy kapjunk ilyen metaforákat most hogy
ezt a hat különböző gondolkodási
módszert ezt a hat különböző alapot
átbeszéltük szeretnék megosztani veletek
30 különböző tippet hogy én hogyan
használom a chat gpt-t még egyszer ez
nem egy kimerítő lista lehetett volna 40
is lehetett volna 50 is viszont ez a 30
nagyjából ad egy olyan mintázatot ami
alapján szerintem már ti is saját
megoldásokat saját ötletekkel jöhettek
valamint már biztos vagyok benne hogy
sokkal kreatívabb és izgalmasabb ötletek
már eddig is léteznek úgyhogy kérlek
kommentbe osszátok meg hogy ha hasonló
tippekkel vagy módszerekkel dolgoztok és
esetleg közkincsét tennétek ti is hogy
tanuljak belőle én is és valójában
mindenki aki ezt a műsort végignézi az
első tipp válasszd szét a chateket
különböző témák szerint azért raktam be
mert valaki aki még sosem használta a
chat gpt-t nem biztos hogy ez magától
értetődő ebben a pillanatban számára is
például a chat gpt-nél több különböző
chatet lehet elindítani és mindegyik
chat egy különböző mikrovilágnak kell
elképzelni ahol egymásról ezek a chatek
nem tudnak vagyis hogyha fel elkezdünk
beszélni valamit az egyik chatbe a másik
chat az nem fog tudni erről semmit na
most nyilván az elmúlt egy-két hónapban
bevezetett a chat gpt egy memória
funkciót ahol külön el tudunk tárolni
bizonyos információkat magunkról ami
viszont meg lesz osztva egy új chattel
minden egyes chat legyen egy újabb
kontextus minden egyes feladat amit
aminek nekiifogunk az legyen egy újabb
chat kettő válassz jól strukturált
címeket a chatek számára én a chat gpt-t
naponta többször használom így
elképzelhetitek hogy 30 nap alatt több
10 vagy akár több mint 100 különböző
chatet is nyitok ilyenkor és úgy tudom
megkülönböztetni a lehető legkönnyebben
őket hogy a címüket külön megadom át
lehet nevezni egy chatet és meg lehet
adni egy chatnek konkrétan hogy mi
legyen a címe ilyenkor több dimenzióban
strukturálom sokszor ilyenkor a címbe
mint menedzser megjelölöm hogy ez melyik
projekttel kapcsolatos vagy akár a
menedzsment pozíciómmal kapcsolatos és
utána pedig aldimenzióként megjelölöm
hogy ez most árajánlat adás al volt
kapcsolatos tegyük fel vagy pedig vagy
pedig egyszerűen egy beszámolót próbálok
létrehozni a jó hír az hogy körülbelül
pár nappal ezelőtt kiadta például a chat
gpt azt hogy különböző mappa
struktúrákba lehet helyezni a chatet
arra számítok hogy a többi ai chatbot is
majd követni fogja a következő hónapban
ezt a strukturálási lehetőséget ennek
ellenére egy jó általános tipp kezdőknek
is akár hogy a címet válaszd meg te
azért hogy könnyen és gyorsan felismerd
magát azt a chatet később is három
ismerd meg és használd az chat alapvető
funkcióit például a chat gpt lehetőséget
ad arra hogy dokumentumokat csatoljunk
például egy pdf dokumentumot hogyha
csatolunk akkor bele tudunk kérdezni
ebbe a pdf dokumentumba ami hihetetlenül
hasznos mert később majd jövök egy olyan
tippel hogy hogyan tudunk nagyon
hatékonyan tanulni a chat gpt
segítségével így ugyanígy képeket lehet
csatolni amiket felismer és tudunk
kérdezni a képekkel kapcsolatban ez
különösen hasznos például amikor
lefényképezünk egy idegen nyelvű
szöveget és megkérjük a chat gpt-t hogy
fordítsa le számunkra például angolra ez
konkrétan akkor történt meg velem amikor
egy kínai étterembe kerültem és a menü
csak kínai karakterekkel
volt olvasható lefényképeztem az oldalt
és gyakorlatilag a chat gpt egy pillanat
alatt lefordította számomra magyarra
rákérdezhettem hogy mi van milyen
összetevők vannak benne megkérdezhettem
hogy milyen ételeket ajánl hogyha
családommal vagyunk itt és kisgyerek
vannak tehát például pikáns étel ne
legyen benne úgyhogy hihetetlenül
hasznos ha tudjuk hogy a chat gpt képes
erre is az egyik funkciója viszont amit
nagyon sokat használok a chat gpt-nek ez
a voice funkció és ezt külön ki
szeretném emelni mindenki számára a
chatgpt képes arra hogy hangüzenetekkel
kommunikáljunk vele az egyik
leghasznosabb az hogy fel tudok diktálni
egy komplex szöveget amit meglepő
pontossággal ismerd fel még akkor is
hogyha magyarul mondom ezt a szöveget az
angolja pedig még pontosabb ez
hihetetlenül hasznos akkor amikor nem
vagyok billentyűzet közelben amikor egy
olyan kontextusban vagyok ahol ahol nem
nagyon tudnék írni és telefonon írni
pedig hosszabb lassabb és pontatlanabb
de gyakran azt csinálom például hogy
kimegyek sétálni egyet a munk közbe és
magát a munkát azt úgy végzem el hogy
séta közben felépítem a kontextust erről
majd később lesz majd szó voice funkciók
között van olyan voice funkció ami egy
konverzációt is szimulál amikor már
konkrétan tudunk beszélgetni és hangosan
válaszol néhányan kedvelik ezt én
számomra annyira nem volt ez hasznos
sokszor nem ért meg pontosan sokszor
belevág a szavamban nem vagyok benne
biztos mindig hogy hogy amit mondtam azt
azt el is jut hozzá úgyhogy én általában
egy másik funkciót szoktam használni
amikor felvehetek egy két-három perces
szöveget és utána pedig azt írott
szöveggé alakítja át valójában az ember
egy-két perc alatt is nagyon sok mindent
el tud mondani úgyhogy az esetek nagy
többségében a chat gpt-vel én hang
hangon keresztül kommunikálok és akár
10-15 perc alatt is nagyon komplex
feladatokat el tudok végezni úgyhogy nem
kell irodai környezetben legyek
ezenkívül minden egyes chatbot különböző
más funkciókat ajánl fel ezeket érdemes
megismerni képeket lehet generálni velük
vannak olyanok amelyekkel hangokat lehet
generálni zenéket lehet generálni
hihetetlenül kreatívan tudjuk majd
használni később más és más kon usban
négy építsd fel a kontextust a chat
kezdetén ez volt az első olyan tipp amit
miután elkezdtem használni rájöttem hogy
milyen mély bölcsesség van mögötte
ilyenkor azt szoktam mondani a chat
gpt-nek hogy szeretnék beszélni erről és
erről a témáról de nem szeretném hogyha
közbeszólna azt szeretném hogy minden
egyes üzenetemre csak okéval válaszoljon
hogy segítsen nekem abban hogy mindent
el tudjak mondani arról ami számomra
fontos ez nagyon hasznos mert rend
szerint hogyha ezt nem mondjuk a
sgpt-nek akkor a válasza egy hosszú
szöveg és egyből megpróbál megoldást
keresni arra a problémára amit még fel
se tudtam tenni viszont hogyha ezt
elmondom neki akkor egy okéval fog
válaszolni a kontextust ettől kezdve fel
tudjuk építeni akár a következő 10
percben leírva vagy akár a voice
funkciót használva hihetetlen
sebességgel lehet
komplex kontextusokat felépíteni például
hogyha szeretnénk írni egy beszámolót
egy klienssel kapcsolatban akkor lehet
hogy 10-15 percre is szükségünk van hogy
minden egyes részletét ami a fejünkben
van azt el tudjuk mondani és ez nagyon
hasznos mert az ember fejében nem
strukturáltan van ott az információ nem
olyan mint egy könyv aminek van
bevezetője egy tartalma és majd egy egy
lezárása hanem bizonyos szempontból
randomra jutnak eszünkben olyan
gondolatok olyan részletek amelyek nem
koherensen egymáshoz kapcsolódnak hanem
bizonyos szempontból véletlenszerűen
jönnek fel bennünk így sokszor
megtörténhet az hogy egy konex ust nem
azonnal 10-15 perc alatt építünk fel
hanem két-három nap alatt velem
konkrétan megtörtént az hogy egy
klienssel kapcsolatban pont egy
beszámolót kellett írjak egy hétvége
során miközben én fával dolgoztam és
kint a kertbe járkáltam és és próbáltam
fizikai munkát végezni itt-ott jöttek
fel gondolatok és ezeket használtam arra
hogy a kontextust felépítsem a hétvége
során körülbelül 30-40 ilyen üzenetet
gyűjtöttem össze a chat gpt számára így
folyamatosan megismerte azt amit én el
szeretnék érni folyamatosan ismerte meg
azt a kontextust amiből a beszámoló
később majd megszületett így hétfőn
körülbelül egy órába telt ameddig az a
beszámoló elkészült öt koncentrálj a
tartalomra és a formát hagyd későbbre az
előző tippben arról meséltem hogy hogyan
építhetünk fel gyorsan egy kontextust
vagy akár hosszabb idő alatt úgy hogy az
információ ami amiből a kontextust
építjük nem feltétlenül koherens módon
jut eszünkbe hanem bizonyos szempontból
össz-evissza véletlenszerűen ha viszont
felépítettük a kontextust akkor abban a
pillanatban sok mindent tudunk kezdeni
ezzel a kontextussal és a bölcsessége
ennek a tippnek az az hogy először
mindig tartalomra koncentrálunk hogy mi
szeretnén mit szeretnénk hogy körülbelül
milyen információ az ami meg fog jelenni
ebben például ebben a beszámolóban és a
formát azt hogy konkrétan hogyan nézzen
ki azt későbbre hagyjuk vagyis amikor
már készen van a a a kontextusunk azt
mondjuk hogy semmilyen más plusz
gondolatot már nem tudok össze
hozzárakni már csak ismétlem újra és
újra azokat a gondolatokat amelyeket
szerettem volna megosztani akkor talán
már készen vagyunk és ekkor jöhet maga a
forma ilyenkor azt mondom a chat gpt-nek
hogy szeretnék egy struktúrát kidolgozni
most ezek a gondolataim milyen más
pontokat javasol amit esetleg mint
alfejezet beleillene ebbe a beszámolóba
és meglepő módon a chat gpt segít ilyen
pont at még kidolgozni úgyhogy lesz
gyakorlatilag egy tartalomjegyzékünk ami
amely amit amit a chat gpt-vel együtt
tudtunk kidolgozni utána megkérdezem a
chat gpt-t minden egyes információ
rendelkezésedre áll-e ahhoz hogy ki tudd
tölteni ezt a beszámolót és meglepő
módon nagyon pontosan meg fogja mondani
hogy ha valahol még hiányos vagy nem
pontosan tiszta hogy mivel lehet ne
kitölteni ebben a pillanatban megkérem
hogy egy első válzatot generáljon
számomra ilyenkor végigolvasom és azt
látom hogy meg megdöbbentően pontos
nagyjából azt írja le amit meg
szeretnénk hogy meg megszeretnénk hogy
jelenjen ebbe a beszámolóba ilyenkor a
chap gptt megkérhetjük majd hogy
bizonyos részeket rövidítsen le mert túl
túl bő bőven írta le és bizonyos
részeket kibővíthet mert tegyük fel tú
túl szűk szavú volt és majd a végén azt
is megkérhetjük hogy ugyanezt a
beszámolót amikor már nagyjából készen
állunk fordítsa le angolra is úgyhogy
javaslom hogy koncentráljunk magára a
tartalomra először és a végén a
struktúrára magára a formára csak a
legvégén hatos készíts kérdőíveket és
felmérést ez egy konkrét felhasználása
annak a tippnek amelyben először a
kontextust gyűjtjük és utána majd a
formát később határozzuk meg például
amíg az előző tippben egy beszámolót
generáltatunk a chat gpt által ebben a
tippben például lehet egy kérdőévet is
tegyük fel hogy a szociológián diákként
tanulok és az egyik vizsgámra szeretnék
egy kérdőívet dolgozni először felépítem
magát a kontextust majd később a
kérdőívet a maga
kérdéseivel nagyon könnyen ki tudjuk
generálni elmondom a javaslataimat
tegyük fel hogy én mire gondoltam és
megkérem a chat gpt-t hogy segítsen
kiegészíteni olyan más kérdésekkel
amelyek egy teljesebb képet fognak majd
eredményezni hetes vizsgáld meg a
témákat több nézőpontból ez tipikusan az
a probléma amikor az ember szubjektív
módon amikor egy komplex témáról kell
gondolkozzon sokszor képtelen kimozdulni
a saját nézőpontjából hogy nagyon
hasznos lenne hogyha valakivel tudna
róla beszélgetni nyilván ilyenkor le
tudunk ülni és több szakembert több
szempontból megvizsgálja de a chat gpt
ebben is tud kiválóan segíteni például
úgy hogy azt mondjuk a chat gpt-nek hogy
szimuláljunk négy különböző karaktert a
b c és d anita béla cecília és dénes
ilyenkor minél több részletet adunk meg
ezekről a személyekről annál pontosabban
tudja majd meghatározni tegyük el anita
egy z
generációs személy aki most
érettségizett nemrég és mint pincér
dolgozik az egyik étteremben béla egy 60
éves szakember aki készül a nyugdíjra
cecília egy programozó és a többi és
akkor ha van egy olyan téma amit meg
kell különböző embereknek a
nézőpontjából vizsgálni akkor
megkérdezhetjük megkérhetjük a chat
gpt-t hogy kezdjen el gondolkozni
ezeknek a személyeknek a fejével hogy
hogyan közelíti meg egy
zgenációs pincér az adott témát hogy
milyen pozitív és akár negatív hozadéka
lehet azoknak a döntéseknek amit
szeretnénk bevezetni a terméken
keresztül nagyon pontos képet fog adni
mert valójában például az én példámat
nézve én egy y generációs programozó
vagyok és azt kellett lássam hogy
teljesen másképp gondolkozok mint egy z
generációs fiatal másképp látjuk a
világot másképp látjuk a a veszélyeket a
világban a háború kérdése az ai kérdése
a házasság kérdése a szexualitás kérdése
teljesen más nézőpontból van
megvilágítva az én szempontomból és egy
z generációs személy számára például
segített nekem konkrétan felkészülni
olyan prezentációra amit tudtam hogy
19-20 éveseknek lesz majd íródva é a
chat gpt-től kértem tanácsot hogy milyen
nyelvvezetet használjak ahhoz hogy
közelebb tudjak kerülni hozzájuk hogy
jobban megértessem magam velük nyolc
igazítsd a tartalom hosszát és stílusát
a célközönséghez ez egy másik
applikációja az előző tippnek valójában
az van hogy a tiktokon ha egy posztot
megszeretnénk jelentetni vagy a
facebookon vagy az instagramon vagy akár
egy céges környezetben egy beszámolóként
vagy egy emailt szeretnénk írni
mindegyiknek megvan a maga stílusa és
hossza ugyanazt az információt amit
tegyük fel a kontextusként felépítettünk
a négyes tipbe ugyanazt az információt
különbözőképpen tudjuk megfor ázni
megkérhetjük a chat gpt-t hogy kérlek
írj egy facebook bejegyzést és használj
olyan stílust ami ami a z generációt
címezi meg vagy kérlek írj egy emailt
ami már formálisabb és tömörebb
megkérhetjük azt is hogy ez most túl
tömörre sikerült legyen egy picit
hosszabb vagy pedig ha egy hosszabb
emailt generáltunk akkor ez
egyszerűsítse le akár mi is megírhatjuk
ezt az emailt és megkérhetjük hogy ezt
próbálj meg kicsit formálisabb
környezetben formálisabb nyelvezettel
újrafogalmazni ez különösen akkor
segíthet számunkra amikor idegen nyelven
fogalmazunk meg egy emailt és nem
vagyunk annak a nyelvnek a mesterei
tehát például amikor angolul írok én egy
emailt azért mégis hogyha formális
környezetben van használva akkor
megkérem a chatgpt-t hogy egyrészt
javítsa ki a hibákat másrészt pedig
segítsen abban hogy formálisabb de mégis
angolos kifejezéseket használó email
születhessen ebből kilences dolgozz ki
különböző típusú dokumentumokat úgy
ahogy a nyolcadik
tippnél említettem különböző formákat
különböző stílusokat lehet a chat
gpt-vel szimulálni ezt azért kiszerettem
volna egy picit jobban bontani ebbe a
kilences tipbe ugyanazt az információt
lehet néha beszámolóként lehet néha
árajánlatként lehet néha konkrétan
például egy éves beszámolóként is
formázni számomra nagyon hasznos az hogy
amikor felépítek egy kontextust utána
gyakorlatilag többféle dokumentumot
tudok ugyanabból a kontextusból kinyerni
tehát tegyük fel az egyik projekttel
kapcsolatban igyekszek lediktálni minden
részletet ki volt a kliens mennyi időt
dolgoztunk együtt mik voltak a kihívások
hogyan indult a a kapcsolat esetleg
bepróbálok másolni mindenféle
dokumentumot ami az elején
projektspecifikációk múltbeli emailek és
ezekből építem fel a kontextust majd
később hogyha szükségem van egy
árajánlatra egy újabb árajánlatra akkor
pillanatok alatt tudok generálni egy
újabb árajánlatot hiszen a kontextus
alapján már egyszerűen fog működni az
hogy hogy a az árajánlat különböző
részleteit ki tudjam dolgozni és csak a
az árajánlatnak a leglényegesebb részét
az árát konkrétan azt én manuálisan
szerkesszem vagy ugyanígy hogyha az
árajánlat után szeretnék egy beszámolót
generálni ugyanabból a kontextusból ezt
könnyedén megtehetem hiszen megadom neki
a struktúráját és ezt a beszámolót
pillanatok alatt azon a nyelven amelyen
szeretném abban a formában és stílusban
amelybe amelybe szeretném ezt ki tudom
nyerni 10-es rendezd a gondolat idat a
mind map módszer segítségével azok
számára akiknek nem ismerős a mindmap
módszer én azt javaslom hogy most
állítsák meg a videót és nézzenek utána
hogy hogyan is lehet használni ezt a
mind map módszert arra hogy komplex
gondolatokat hogyan lehet megérteni és
megjegyezni az egy vizuális módszer ahol
a különböző fogalmaknak az egymáshoz
vett relációját meg tudjuk jegyezni és
egymáshoz képes hierarchikusan el tudjuk
rendezni ugyanis az történik sokszor
hogy a fejünkben az információ nincs
rendezve mentáltan jelenik meg mint
például akár egy meeting esetében is
amikor leülünk egy tárgyalás során
beszélgetni és két órán keresztül
beszélget öt ember ide-oda kalandozva
nehéz megmondani konkrétan miről is
szólt az a a megbeszélés ilyenkor
jegyzetelhetünk
utólag igyekez igyekezhetünk
rekonstruálni hogy miről beszélgettünk
viszont nagyon hasznos lenne hogyha
valami vagy valaki össze tudná számunkra
fogadni foglalni hogy miről szól miről
szólt az a megbeszélés é és ilyenkor
vizuálisan látnánk hogy beszélgettünk
erről a témáról ennek a témának volt
három altémája annak a három altémának
volt egyenként négy öt vagy egy másik
téma és akkor volt egy másik téma amiről
beszélgettünk és gyakorlatilag mint egy
gráf a fejünkben mint egy térkép úgy
tudjuk majd átlátni magát a megbeszélést
ugyanez történik ilyenkor a mindmap
módszer segítségével amikor egy
kontextust felépítünk megkérhetjük a
chatgpt-t hogy segítsen ebből egy mind
mapet készíteni a fő több fogalmakat
helyezze hierarchikus sorrendbe és
azáltal sokkal tisztábbá válik számunkra
is hogy konkrétan mi az ami bennünk van
ez fordítva is érvényes hogyha azt
szeretnénk hogy egy mind map módszer
segítségével egy komplex témát
kibontsunk mint például tegyük fel
szeretnék indítani egy youtube csatornát
akkor megkérem a chat gpt-t hogy a
négy-öt ezzel társuló feladatot segítsen
jobban megérteni ilyenkor hozz nekünk
egy listát ahhoz hogy egy youtube
csatornád legyen először is kell
gondolkozz magánat a tartal van legyen
egy címe legyen egy brandje legyen
valami amiről szól ezenkívül válasz ki
azokat a közösségi média platformokat
ahol majd szeretnéd ezt a tartalmat
megosztani ezen kívül szükséged lesz
valószínűleg egy gazdasági keretre
mennyi pénz szánsz erre mennyi időt
szánsz erre és satöbbi satöbbi a chatgpt
segít felhozni azokat az ezzel társuló
kihívásokat feladatokat amelyeket meg
kell egyenként oldani és tegyük fel hogy
az a chat gptt megkérdez hetjük utána
hogy rendben segíts akkor mélyebben
megérteni ezt a közösségi platformokat
milyen közösségi platformok vannak
melyiknek milyen a tulajdonsága esetleg
hogyha el tudom mondani neki hogy milyen
típusú anyagra gondoltam
amit podcast formájáb tegyük fel akkor
el tudja mondani hogy melyek azok a
platformok ahol ez a formátum ebben a
hosszban javasolt például a youtube
inkább alkalmasabb arra hogy hosszú
formátumú podcastteket osszunk meg de
ugyanígy a spotify vagy a a újabban az x
is viszont a az instagram és a tiktok
azok rövid tartalmakra vannak
optimizálva szóval egy komplex témát
hasonlóan ahogy egy könyvtárstuktúrát is
böngészünk a számítógépen ki lehet
bontani és a chat gpt is segít számunkra
hogy ezeket a komplex fogalmakat
megértsük és hogy hogyan kapcsolódnak
egymáshoz 11 kezelj emaileket hatékonyan
ez már egy haladóbb technika minden
egyes emailnek valójában a hátterében
egy forráskód van ez a forráskód sokkal
több információt tartalmaz mint amit
konkrétan egy email kliens ki is jelez
általában csak szöveget látunk vagy
egy-két képet a az emailbe de az email
valódi tartalmában a háttérben rengeteg
információ rejlik abban hogy honnan jött
ez az email ki küldte ezt az emailt
milyen kontextusba küldte és sokszor az
van hogy az emailnek történelmében
úgymond az összes más email tehát
gyakorlatilag a teljes beszélgetés benne
van most tegyük fel hogy kapunk egy
emailt mert 10 ember beszélget ett egy
projektről és becsatoltak minket is egy
hosszú beszélgetés után egyrészt nehezen
olvasható egy ilyen email ahol teljes
múltat végig kell böngésszük ki kinek
írt mikor melyik cégtől pontosan és
milyen szándékkal ez akár egy fél órát
órát is igé igénybe vehet egy-egy email
esetében akár még többet hogyha pontosan
nem is ismerjük a kontextust viszont ha
az emailnek a forráskódját kimásoljuk és
megkérjük a chat gpt-t hogy segítsen
tájékozódni ebben az emailben
megdöbbentő eredmény hez jutunk például
megkérdez megkérdezhetjük a chat gpt-t
hogy kik azok a személyek akik ebben az
emailben részt vesznek és akkor hoz egy
listát arról hogy kik azok a személyek
akik akik beszélgetnek megkérdezhetjük
hogy milyen pozícióban dolgoznak ezek a
személyek mit lehet tudni róluk és
ilyenkor megdöbbentően pontos dolgokat
ki tud következtetni akár az email
címüknek a domain részéből ki tudnak
következtetni dolgokat vagy az
aláírásokból a kikövetkeztetik a pozíció
ott magából a szövegkontextusból
következtetik ki hogy ki milyen
relációban van van amikor semmit nem
lehet tudni egy adott személyről csak
azt hogy valószínűleg a háttérben van de
kiövetkezteti hogy valószínűleg ő a ceo
mert az egyik aláírásban minthogyha
látta volna ezt és és rengeteg időt
megspórolhat számunkra hogy átlássuk
konkrétan egy email beszélgetés emailen
történő beszélgetésnek a a részleteit
például egyszer megtörtént velem az hogy
egy ilyen email beszélgetést bemásoltam
és a végén megkérdeztem hogy egy
árajánlatot kérnek tőlünk hogyha
feltételezem hogy az a projekt 400
munkaórát fog igénybe venni akkor
mennyibe kerülhetne ez a projekt és csak
ennyit kérdeztem tőle ugyanis magában az
emailben a beszélgetésben beszéltek
órabérekről beszéltek különböző projekt
specifikus dolgokról és megdöbbentő volt
számomra hogy a chat gpt képes volt
kikövetkeztetni ebből egy elég pontos
árajánlatot meg kell jegyezzem itt hogy
céges kontextusban nem mindig szabad ezt
megtennünk hogy kiás juk az emailnek a
forráskódját és felhasználjuk ha ti
megtehetitek én ajánlom a figyelmetekben
ezt minden egyes email kliensnél legyen
az yaho vagy outlook lehetőségetek van
arra hogy hozzáférjetek az emailnek a
forráskódjához 12 hosszabb tartalmakat
foglalj össze chat gpt segítségével én
ezt akkor tanultam meg amikor a saját
csatornámra szerettem volna felkészülni
hogy hogyan lehet hatékonyan egy
csatornát üzemeltetni hogyan lesz egy
csatorna népszerű és ahogy elkezdtem
nézni ilyen videókat egyre több hasonló
videót dobott fel számomra általában azt
tapasztaltam hogy kevés volt az
információtartalma viszont nem zéró
érdemes volt megnézni őket de 10 percet
nem volt érdemes eltölteni velük és
aztán utána jött az ötlet hogy sokszor
felajánlja a chat gpt az automata
feliratozást azt be tudom kapcsolni sőt
külön vannak erre szolgáltatások hogy
hogyan lehet a feliratát egy youtube
videónak elérni próbáld meg ezeket a a a
módszereket próbáld meg kimásolni magát
a youtube videónak a feliratát és
bemásolod a chat gpt-be és megkérheted
azt hogy foglalja ezt össze újabban
láttam chrome bővítményeket is amelyek
ugyanezt csinálják maga az alapelv az
ugyanaz hogyha el tudod érni hogy
szöveges formátumban egy egy videót vagy
bármilyen más tartalmat elérj akkor
remek eszköz a chat gpt arra hogy a
lényeget kivonja belőle 13 meeting
videókat foglalj össze vele ez egy másik
alkalmazása az előző hosszú formátumú
tartalmaknak de ezt külön azért írtam le
mert vannak olyan meetingek amiket amúgy
is felveszünk amúgy is rögzítve vannak
ilyenkor használhatunk egy szolgáltatást
amelyik kinyeri egy meetingből magát a
hangfát és a hangfightt át tudjuk
alakítani felirattá erre vannak
szolgáltatások és akkor megint a
feliratot tudjuk arra használni hogy
akár egy mind mapet generáljon ki
számunkra a különböző fogalmakkal és a
köztük levő relációkkal úgyhogy rengeteg
időt megspórol számotokra tegyük fel
hogyha van egy két órás meeting ahol öt
ember beszélgetett és a végén
szeretnétek egy egy összefoglalót
küldeni hogyha újra vissza kell
hallgassátok azt a videót azért hogy
most már részletesebben jegyzetelve egy
pontosabb jegyzőkönyvet tudj írni ennél
sokkal hatékonyabb módszer az hogyha
kinyered a hangft ebből egy szöveges
formátumot generálsz és megkéred a chat
gpt-t hogy ezt az összefoglaló
jegyzőkönyvet számodra készítse el 14-es
érvelj és tanulj érvelni a chat gpt-vel
nagyon nehéz dolog érvelni ez egy külön
művészet megtanulni úgy megközelíteni
egy témát hogy a lehető legerősebbek leg
legyenek az érveid én ezt legutoljára
úgy használtam hogy az egyik műsoromra
megpróbáltam felkészülni és a másik fél
álláspontját szerettem volna k
képviselni de az az igazság hogy én a
saját buborékomban élek a környezetemben
a legtöbben keresztények és a legtöbben
egyetértenek velem vagy pedig aki nem
ért egyet velem általában nincs is
véleménye ritka az a személy akivel
érdemben tudok vitázni viszont ahhoz
hogy felkészüljek egy vitára kiválóan
alkalmas a chat gpt megkérhetem hogy
tegyük fel most az egyik tipikus
vitaforrás az a a globális felmelegedés
ha én az egyik oldalt képviselem
megkérhetem hogy a chat gpt képviselje a
másik oldalt megkérhetem arra hogy
ahányszor megpróbálok érvelni próbáljam
meg analizálni az érveimet adjon egy
számot például egy-től 10-ig hogy
mennyire volt erős az érvem segítsen
abban hogy még erőteljesebbé tudjam
tenni az érveimet és utána próbáljon meg
válaszolni a lehető legjobb érvekkel és
azt vettem észre hogy egyszerűen meg
döbbentő hogy milyen rövid idő alatt
tudom megismerni a másik félnek az
álláspontját sőt ha alázatosan figyelek
rájövök arra hogy hol vannak az én
érveimnek a a gyengepontjai 15-ös járd
körbe a témákat több nézőpontból is
erről már egy picit beszélgettünk ezt
csak röviden fogom megemlíteni az előző
tippnél arról beszéltünk hogy hogyan
próbáljunk meg megtanulni érvelni itt
valójában ennek egy általánosabb
formájáról van szó amikor körbe akarunk
járni egy témakört akkor kérhetjük a
chat gpt-t hogy világítsa meg több
nézőpontból segítsen abban hogy
megértsük ezt a témát a lehető
legkplexebb nézőpontokból is például egy
gyakorlati példa hogy én mint menedzser
megpróbálok kidolgozni egy terméket a
cégünk számára ezt a terméket meg kell
tudjam közelíteni és el kell tudjam
magyarázni egy ügyfélnek de ugyanakkor
el kell tudjam magyarázni a felső
vezetők számára is de ugyanúgy a csapat
számára is ugyan aki ezt a szolgáltatást
szolgáltatni fogja a három különböző
nézőpont bár ugyanarról beszélünk lehet
teljesen más is a chat gpt segíthet
abban hogy a különböző nézőpontokat szét
tudjuk választani és megtanuljunk azzal
a nyelvezettel beszélni ami abból a
nézőpontból releváns 16-os vizsgáld meg
a témákat több forrásból is bizonyos
témaköröket nagyon nehéz objektívan
megközelíteni politikai gazdasági
vallási vagy egyéb témaköröket néha
annyira toxikus megközelíteni annyira
ált a világunk hogy egy teljes képet
nehezen tudunk kapni ilyenkor például a
chat gpt-t megkérhetjük hogy keressen
különböző forrásokat tegyük fel
balliberális sajtóból és és konzervatív
sajtóból például az amerikai
választásoknál ezt gyakran alkalmaztam
hogy a demokrata és a republikánus
források minthogyha a homlokegyenes mást
mondtak volna ugyanarról az eseményről
így megkérhetjük hogy keressen három
forrást a demokrata oldalról három
forrást a republikánus oldalról és
próbálja meg ezeket rangsorolni
összesíteni hogy egy teljesebb képet
tudjun kapni magáról arról a a az
eseményről 17-es kombináld és hasonlítsd
össze és ellenőrizd a nézőpontokat
különböző modellekkel eddig nagyjából a
chat gpt-ről beszélgettem viszont van jó
pár más népszerű modell ilyen a gemini
vagy a grock ami ugyancsak elérhető
ezeket a modelleket viszont mivel
bizonyos adatokból tanították ezért
bizonyö szempontból elfogultak és
hajlamosabbak egy tipikus módon
válaszolni erre például az egyik
botrányos és talán vicces példa az
amikor a gemini elindította magát a
képgeneráló funkcióját és körülbelül egy
már nem is emlékszem talán egy éve volt
ez és nem volt hajlandó fehér embert
generálni ugyanis egy annyira át volt
ittatva egy walk ideológiával hogy
számára csak színes bőrűek és
kisebbségek léteztek azonnal le is
állították ezt a modellt de nem lehetett
ez gyorsan kijavítani tehát nem az volt
hogy pár nap után egy másik modellel
jöttek és ez korrigálva volt hanem ez
megint újratanítást hosszúhosszú időt
igényelt minden egyes modell ilyen
szempontból egy picit másképp működik
vannak modellek amelyek alkalmasabbak
hosszú kontextust befogadni egy hosszabb
dokumentummal dolgozni ilyen például a
cloud vannak olyan modellek amelyek
inkább alkalmasak arra hogy kreatív
ötletekkel jöjjenek és más nézőpontokat
kö hozzanak be amikre esetleg még nem
gondoltunk ilyen például grock az
xai-tól és a chat gpt-nek is megvan a
maga előnye hogyha egy olyan témát
szeretnénk kidolgozni amelyek tényleg
meg lesz vizsgálva tegyük fel egy
tudományos dolgozat vagy egy
disszertáció és és szeretnék szeretnénk
több szempontból több modellel
ellenőrizni hogy az az információ amit
kaptunk ez tényleg helyes-e nem elegendő
több forrást megkeresni mint az előző
tvbe több honlapról hanem én ezt úgy
csinálnám hogy különböző modelleken
ugyanazt az eredményt lefuttatnám addig
ameddig konszenzus lesz legalábbis
bennem nyugalom lesz azzal kapcsolatban
hogy a végtermék kellően jó
minőségű dolgozz egyszerre párhuzamosan
több modellel ez abban különbözik az
előző tipptől hogy itt valójában nem az
van hogy egymást leellenőrizzük hanem
valójában az egyiknek az outputja a
kimenetele a másiknak az inputja lesz
vagyis a bemenetele megkérhetjük a chat
gpt-t hogy generáljon ki egy véleményt
például egy vitával kapcsolatban egy
állás pontot és megkérjük tegyük fel a
grockot hogy válaszoljon elre az
álláspontra és jöjjön újabb
szempontokkal majd utána visszaadhatjuk
ezt az információt a chat gpt-nek és
majd utána megint a grocknak hagyjuk
hogy a két modell egymással beszélgessen
rend szerint ez sokkal pontosabb
eredményhez vezet minthogyha önmagában
csak egy modellt használnánk 18-as
generálj metaforákat és analógiákat
erről beszélgettünk a gondolkodási
alapoknál hogy az ember sokkal
könnyebben ért meg egy komplex fogalmat
hogyha egy metaforát ami sokkal
egyszerűbb vagy egy analógiát be tud
hozni ebbe a képbe például amiután
felépítettük a kontextust vagy
elkezdtünk elkezdtünk egy komplex
dokumentumot tanulmányozni esetleg egy
tankönyvet pdf formá formájába
csatoltunk és szeretnénk megérteni egy
fogalmat megkérdezhetjük a chat gpt-t
hogy milyen példát tudnál hozni erre a
működésre mi a véleményed erről hogy
milyen metafora illene a leg leginkább
erre a komplex fogalon rendszerre és
megdöbbentő hogy mennyire pontos
metaforá at képes generálni
gyakorlatilag azt az ah pillanatot
amikor hirtelen rájövünk valamire
azonnal meg megkérhetjük a chat gpt-t
hogy segítsenb ha elkezditek használni
egyszerűen megdöbbentő az hogy mennyire
hatékony és jól és találó metaforákat
képes találni olyan fogalmakra amelyeket
egyszerűen addig nehezen tudtunk
megérteni valahogy úgy nem kattant be az
az ah pillanat nem jött el 19-es tanulj
összefoglalással talán addig igazán nem
értünk valamit egy komplex fog i
rendszert amí nem vagyunk képesek
elmagyarázni nagy nagyon ötletesen lehet
építeni erre a gondolatra a chat gpt-vel
többször például előfordult velem hogy
egy jogi szöveget másoltam be ami nem
volt annyira tiszta számomra elolvastam
de úgy csak úgy derengett bennem
körülbelül hogy miről is szólhat
ilyenkor elmondhatom a chat gpt-nek hogy
szeretném az 1.9-es pontot összefoglalni
körülbelül ezt értettem meg és a saját
szavaimmal elmondom a chat gpt-nek mi az
amit megértettem és megkérem a chat
gpt-t hogy mondjon véleményt arról
mennyire pontos és ilyenkor rendszerint
nagyon pontosan azt mondja hogy
eltaláltad ez tényleg így van viszont
ezt és ezt és ezt pontosítani érdemes
benne vagy pedig azt mondja hogy nem
egészen erről van szó talán érdemesebb
így gondolni erre az 1.9-es pontra
gyakorlatilag azáltal hogy megpróbáljuk
összefoglalni a saját szavainkkal
miközben összefoglaljuk mi is jobban
megértjük magát azt az 1.9-es pontot
úgyhogy javaslom hogyha egy komplex
dokumentumot néztek át próbáljátok meg
összefoglalni és a chatgpt is segíteni
fog abban hogy ellenőrizze hogy amit
megértettünk ez tényleg helyes-e vagy
pedig nem 20-as készíts személyre
szabott oktatási anyagot hogyha
szeretnénk egy új területet megismerni
valamit amely ami ami számunkra addigi
teljesen ismeretlen volt ilyen volt
számomra a cloud technológiáknak a a
részletesebb megismerése akkor
megkérhetjük a chat gpt-t hogy segítsen
számunkra egy személyre szabott oktatási
anyagot kidolgozni ilyenkor elmondhatjuk
a chat gpt-nek hogy mi a célunk hogy
hova szeretnénk eljutni hogy mi az a az
anyag amit át szeretnénk nézni és én
ilyenkor rend szerint egy átfogó képet
szeretnék először kapni mielőtt még a
mélységeig mélységeig megértek egy
információt ilyenkor megkérem a chat
gpt-t hogy segítsen egy tananyagot
kidolgozni amelynek a fejezeteit
körülbelül két perc alatt elolvashatom
és amikor azt mondom hogy most akkor
menjen a következő fejezetre így azokban
az időkben is amikor nem feltétlenül van
másra időm két perc azért mégis csak
került tegyük fel most kell várjak egyik
ismerősömre és szeretnék haladni azzal
az anyaggal akkor azt mondom a chat
gpt-nek visszamegyek ahhoz a chathez
kikeresem és azt mondom hogy most vagy
jöhet a következő és akkor jön a
következő fejezet és ilyen mikroidőkben
el tudok olvasni 20-30 fejezetet arról a
tananyagról azzal a tananyaggal
kapcsolatban és egy átfogó képet kapok
magáról arról a fogalomról amit meg
szerettem volna ismerni hogyha pedig
szeretnék mélyebbre menni tehát az
átfogó képen kép nem elegendő hanem
szeretném mélyebben megérteni akkor
bármikor megállhatunk és azt
megkérdezhetem a chat gpt-től hogy hogy
ezt pontosan hogyan működik és akkor ha
még mélyebbre szeretnék menni akkor még
mélyebben megérteni azt hogy ez az anyag
hogyan működik ez a ez a fogalom
pontosan mit is takar például amikor a
cloud technológiákat próbáltam átnézni
akkor magával a az adatrögzítési
technológiával kapcsolatban szerettem
volna megérteni hogy milyen különböző
típusú adatrögzítők vannak és megérteni
azt hogy valójában még ma is a mai nap
is használnak szalagos adatrögzítést
ráadásul ez egy nagyon hatékony és olcsó
módszer arra hogy rengeteg információt
tároljunk olcsó és elérhető módon és
akkor meg megkérdeztem hogy melyek a
legújabb termékek milyen típusú
adatrégzítők vannak hány terabte-ot
képes ez tárolni mennyire gyors mennyire
megbízható ezeket ezek már részletesebb
információk amelyekre az átfogó kép
során nem került lehetőségem megismerni
viszont bár bármikor dönthetek úgy hogy
megkérdezem a a chat gpt-t arról hogy
pontosan hogyan is működik ez 21 tanulj
nyelveket a chat gpt segítségével
bizonyos szempontból a nyelvtanulás
részét egy tippbe összefoglalni bűn
annyi mindenre lehet használni és
annyiféleképpen lehet használni én egy
pár javaslatot fogok majd így hozni de
gyanítom hogy a komment részben fogunk
ennél sokkal többet látni ugyanis
rengeteg rengeteg felhasználási módja
van a fordításnak az leg primitívebb
formája az az volt amikor egy a az
online világban amikor egy szótárat
használtunk és beírtuk a szót és és
utána lefordította számunkra azt az
adott nyelvre ennél sokkal mágikusabb
volt amikor a google translate megjelent
és már egy fogalmat tudtunk beírni és
már a kontextusát nagyjából a fogalomnak
értve már nem szóról szóra fordította
hanem hanem egy sokkal pontosabb
fordítást eredményezett viszont bizonyos
szempontból a google translate is elég
vicces volt amikor egy hosszabb szöveget
más voltunk be egyszerűen képtelen volt
kontextusába fordítani azt a szöveget a
chat gpt ilyen szempontból megdöbbentő
ugyanis a kontextusát felismerve egy
adott könyvnek vagy egy
adott bekezdésnek is akár nagyon pontos
fordítást eredményhez és ilyen
szempontból le tudunk fordítani egy
komplex jogi szöveget bármilyen nyelvről
most már bármilyen nyelvre valamind ha
szeretnénk akkor egy könyvet csatolunk
egy pdf-et és megkérhetjük hogy azt
különböző fejezeteket fordítsa le
számunkra és a pont a fordítása
megdöbbentően pontos lesz ez az egyik
módja ahogyan rendszeresen használom a
másik módja az akár egy idegen nyelvet
tudunk gyakoroltatni megkérhetjük hogy
feladatokat generáljon számunkra
megkérhetjük azt hogy segítsen megérteni
egy nyelvtani fogalmat megérteni hogy
pontosan honnan jön egy szónak az
eredetét hogy a történelem során hogyan
alakult át az a szó gyakorlatilag nincs
olyan
kérdés a nyelvekkel kapcsolatban amiben
nem tudna annyira jól válaszolni mint a
világ legjobb nyelvészei ráadásul most
azt hiszem hogy 150 vagy 160 nyelven tud
a chat gpt és a többi nyelv nagynyelvi
modellek is egyre inkább ebbe az irányba
indulnak el hogy egyre pontosabbak
legyenek más nyelveken is nem csak
angolon de önmagában a c gpt már egy egy
csoda hihetetlenül jól beszél úgy
angolul mint románul de akármilyen
számunkra egzotikus vagy akár holt
nyelven is megkérhetjük például hogy
beszéljen a hobbitok nyelvén vagy
tündenyelven
egyszerűen megdöbbentő úgyhogy
használjátok arra hogy nyelveket
tanuljatok és gyakoroljatok 22 használj
aktív fordítást a kommunikációhoz egy
másik
felhasználása míg az előző tipben inkább
a nyelvtanulásra koncentráltam ez egy
érdekes új felhasználása ugyanis a
mostani voice funkcióval egy
beszélgetést tudunk szimulálni amikor
megszólalunk akkor rend szerint figyel
és amikor elhallgatunk akkor rend
szerint valamit válaszol nagyon
egyszerűen betaníthatjuk a chat gpt-t
például ha én angolul mondok valamit
akkor azt mindig fordítsa le magyarra és
csak azt ismételje meg ha magyarul
mondok valamit akkor azt fordítsa le
angolra és csak azt ismételje meg ez
legyen a válasza most tegyük fel hogy
találkozunk valakivel egy angol
anyanyelvű valakivel és mi nem beszélünk
angolul hogyha magyarul mondok valamit a
chat gpt-nek akkor meg fogja ismételni
angolul és ezt a másik személy is hallja
hogyha válaszol nekünk angolul azonnal
fordítani fogja ezt magyarra és mivel a
kontextusa alapján megdöbbentően jól
válaszol ez egy nagyon érdekes új
lehetősége annak hogy megértessük
magunkat egy teljesen idegen nyelvű
személlyel akinek a nyelvén nem
beszélünk most ez lehet akár kínai is
orosz arab bármilyen más nyelv is
evezzünk egy más területre is a 23-as
tipp használd a chat gpt-t a stratég
tervet kidolgozására tegyük fel van
valami amit el szeretnél érni valamilyen
termék amit bevezetnél vagy pedig más
üzleti körülmények között vett
stratégiai cél amit szeretnél jobban
kidolgozni de ez akár biznisz
körülményeken kívül is ezerszer
történhet meg hogy valamiről szeretnénk
egy tervet hozni elmondhatjuk a chat
gpt-nek magát a kontextust hogy hova
szeretnénk eljutni majd pedig
megkérdezhetjük hogy ő hogyan javasolja
hogyan bontsuk le ezt a komplex
problémát egyszerű problémákra és azokat
hogyan tudjuk még egyszerűbb problémákra
bontani olyan megvalósítható
akciótervhez tervekre lebontani amik
amelyeket meg tudunk már konkrétan
csinálni hihetetlenül nagy segítség lesz
ebben is a chat gpt én ezt már többször
próbáltam 24-es ötletelj együtt a chat
gpt-vel néha arra van szükségünk hogy
valamilyen kreatív ötlet jöjjön fel és
szeretnénk egy brainstorming sessionbe
részt venni a chat gpt-vel együtt
elmondhatjuk a kontextust és
megkérhetjük hogy jöjjön 10 különböző
ötlettel valamelyik ötlet lehet hogy
pont megtetszik nekünk azt tovább tudjuk
finomítani nagyon alkalmas a chat gpt
mindenféle kreatív szempontból
megközelíteni a az adott témát a grock
ilyen szempontból állítólag még jobb
mint a chat gpt én valójában mind a
kettőt zseniálisnak látom rengeteg
ötlettel jöttek eddig és ez bizonyos
szempontból egy későbbi tippnél is meg
fog jelenni hogy hogyan tudjunk
generálni mindenféle új nézőpontokat és
íme itt egy gyakorlati alkal azása 25-ös
generálj meséket és történeteket ezt
józsa levente barátom tanította nekem és
nagyon hálás vagyok ez valójában egy
újabb lámpát gyújtott fel bennem egy
történetmesélés valójában egy kreatív
történeti szálnak a a a folyamatos
kibontása és megkérhetjük a chat gpt-t
hogy ebbe vegyen részt úgy hogy együtt
alkossuk azt a történetet és akkor
elkezdjük magát a történetet és megkér
megkérjük a chat gpt-t hogy időnként
álljon meg és kérdezz meg meg minket
hogy hogyan folytatódjon az a történet
és ilyenkor lehetőségünk van
befolyásolni a történetnek a kimenetelét
ő majd tovább bontja ki ezeket a
szálakat és ez egy remek szórakozás
lehet például a gyermekeinkkel hogy
leülünk és kitaláljuk a történet elejét
egyszer volt hol nem volt volt egyszer
egy király amelyiknek volt három
gyermeke és akkor ebből a cat gpt elkezd
egy történetet szőni és időnként
megkérdezi hogy mi történjenek ezekkel a
királyfikkal a ezekkel a gyerekekkel és
a gyerekek pedig lelki en vesznek részt
ebbe a kreatív folyamatba ami egy újabb
interaktív módja hogy hogyan lehet a
digitális világgal kapcsolódni és egy
pozitív élményként megélni mert akár ezt
szöveg helyet akár voice funkcióként is
lehet használni ahol konkrétan
beszélgetünk magával a felnőtt
jelenlétében amúgy ezt mindig ajánlom
hogy a felnőtt is jelen legyen együtt
kitalálni ezt a mesét és ennek a
folytatását 26-os használd a chat gpt-t
arra hogy utazási tippeket kapj ezt
azért raktam be mert ez egy konkrét
konkrét alkalmazása de ehhez hasonló
ötletek százával jöhetnek nemrég voltam
svédországbaan gteborba és fogalmam se
volt hogy mihez kezdjek a gyermekeimmel
ugyanis már délután volt be volt
sötétedve egy picit szemerkélt is az eső
és szerettem volna kimenni sétálni egyet
megkérdeztem a végül a chat gptt hogy
mit ajánl egy három gyerekes
családapának ahol ahol a gyerekek ennyi
és ennyi évesek és szeretnék káb két óra
órát eltölteni és egyből jött négy-öt
javaslattal ja igen és elmondtam hogy
melyik utcában lakok göteborba és egyből
jött a chat gpt négy-öt javaslattal
amelyek egész jók voltak végül nem azt
választottuk egyiket se ezekből az
ötletekből de elgondolkodtatod hogy
mennyi hely ismerete van mennyire
részletesen érti hogy az adott helyen
ahol most vagyunk milyen lehetőségek
vannak egy három gyerekes családapa
számára és valójában ezek jó ötletek
voltak az hogy nem ezt választottuk
annak sem köze nem volt ahhoz hogy
milyen minőségű volt a válasz úgyhogy
használd arra hogy utazási tippeket
generáltass a chat gpt-vel 28-as
automatizáld a napi feladataidat ez
szinte egy magától értetődő lehetőség
amit a chat gpt felkíál számunkra ezt
inkább azért raktam be hogy kiérezzük
hogy mennyire általánosan lehet a chat
gpt-t bármire használni tegyük fel van
egy repetitív feladat egy beszámoló amit
minden héten meg kell írjunk szinte
magától értetődő hogy elmondjuk a
kontextust hogy ezt minden héten meg
kell írjuk és a beszámolóhoz szükséges
plusz információt mindig minden egyes
héten ha leírjuk akkor ebből egy jól
strukturált beszámolót fog tudni
számunkra írni amelyet minden egyes
héten automatikusan meg el fog tudni
számunkra készíteni és ezzel
drasztikusan lerövidíti azt az időt
amennyibe amúgy kerülne hogyha ezt a
beszámolót kézzel csinálnánk megát 29-es
készülj fel egy interjúra a chat gpt
segítségével v ez is egy következménye
az előző tippeknek de szerettem volna
egy praktikus másik felhasználást is
megemlíteni tegyük fel készülünk egy
céghez és interjúra szeretnénk készülni
a chat gpt kiválóan tudja szimulálni ezt
az interjút először is rákereshetünk
magára a cégreel megkérhetjük a chat
gpt-t hogy segítsen megérteni hogy ez a
cég mivel foglalkozik pontosan és
valójában melyek azok a kérdések
amelyekre számíthatunk akár megkérhetjük
a chat gpt-t hogy tegye fel ezeket a
kérdéseket és a válasz ink alapján
segítsen hogy minél inkább fel tudjunk
készülni minél pontosabb válaszokat
tudjunk adni gyakorlatilag egy fél óra
alatt annyira jól fel tudunk készülni
egy ilyen interjúra hogy talán mi magunk
is meg fogunk lepődni 30 tanulj tippeket
generáltatva ezt tudatosan hagytam a
végére ugyanis ez talán egy olyan méltó
lezárása ennek a 30-as listának amelyik
valójában kinyitja a kaput és újabb és
újabb és újabb ötlet et fog majd hozni
mindenki számára amikor belelkesedtem
hogy mennyi mindenre tudom használni a
chat gpt-t szerettem volna megérteni
hogy vajon milyen más lehetőségek
merülnek még fel és megkértem a chat
gpt-t hogy úgy ahogy a a különböző
szoftvereknél amikor elindul egy
szoftver tippeket dob fel hogy hogyan
lehet azt a szoftvert használni
megkértem azt hogy tanítson meg engem
hogy hogyan lehet használni téged vagyis
a chat gpt-t és a chat gpt-t ugyanakkor
megkértem hogy minden egyes tippnek
legyen egy címe legyen egy rövid leírása
és esetleg egy besorolása hogy ez kezdő
középhaladó vagy pedig haladó tipp és
megkértem a chat gpt-t hogy segítsen
abban hogy adjon tippeket hogy hogyan
használjam őket kreatívan és az első jó
pár tipp az első 10 15 20 tipp újabb és
újabb aspektusát tárta fel számomra a
chat gpt-nek hogy hogyan lehet használni
egy idő után már kezdtek ismétlődni ezek
a felhasználási módok úgyhogy utána
megkértem hogy egyszerre már öt utána
már egyszerre 10 tippet generálj
és a végén már odáig eljutottam hogy
több 100 ilyen tipp után úgy éreztem
hogy most már annyi minden aspektusából
megvilágított a számomra hogy hogyan
lehet a chat gpt-t használni hogy már
kezdenek ismétlődni úgyhogy valamilyen
szempontból ez a tananyag amit itt
megpróbáltam számotokra összegyűjteni
ennek a tippeknek a sorozata ennek a
desztilációja és ezeket szerettem volna
mint számomra kiásott kincsként
megosztani veletek úgyhogy ha
szeretnétek egy egy adott
területen belül jobban tájékozódni néha
ez a módszer hogy megkértek tippeket
generáljon megkéritek hogy a cgpt
tippeket generáljon talán a
leghasznosabb és a leghatékonyabb módja
megismerni hogy hogyan lehet azt az
adott területet a lehető legjobban
használni hogyan lehet belátni
megismerni köszönöm szépen hogy velem
tartottatok befejezésként azt tudom
nektek mondani hogy ez az anyag pontosan
azért készült hogy meghozhassam veletek
ezeket a kincseket és szeretném hogyha
együtt gondol koznánk tovább amit
láthatjátok ezek olyan tippek amelyeket
általánosan lehet használni és akár
lehetett volna ez a lista 4050 vagy 100
tipp hosszúságú mert annyiféleképpen
lehet a chat gpt-t használni szóval
legyen ez egy közös gondolkodásnak a
platformja kezdjünk el beszélgetni és
tanítsuk egymást hiszen a
produktivitásunk ezáltal merőben
növekedhet hogyha elkezdjük használni
ezt a az ai alapú chatbotot láthatjátok
hogy bizonyos szempontból ezek a tippek
csak a jéghegy csúcsát jelentik hogy
hogyan lehet az ai chatbotokat használni
mégis egy jó
átfogóképet igyekeztem összeállítani ha
viszont ti másképpen használjátok akkor
írjátok le kommentben szeretnék tőletek
tanulni és szeretném hogyha mindenki
tanulhatna mindenkitől és megtanulnánk
használni ezeket az ai lapu chatbotokat
hogy a produktivitásunk növekedjen az új
év kezdetével ez talán egy jó cél lehet
hogy igyekszünk hatékonyabban elvégezni
azt amit eddig elvégeztünk hogy jusson
idő másra is ami számunkra talán még
fontosabb az elmúlt egy év során amikor
kísérleteztem a chat gpt-vel
megfogalmazódott bennem egy üzenet ami
bizonyos szempontból ezt a félelmet ami
amit az elején tapasztaltam ezt
feloldotta azt látom hogy minden ami
bennünk gépi azt a chat gpt képes lesz
majd szimulálni és minden bennünk ami
emberi azt nem például amikor egy
szöveget írunk maga a helyesírás
ellenőrzés a a gondolatoknak a
strukturálása az egy gépiesies folyamat
ezt meg lehet tanulni ezt lehet elég
exakt módon elvégezni viszont a kreatív
folyamat miközben a szöveget írjuk az
emberi és ezt nem fogja tudni a chat gpt
helyettesíteni
úgy mint szabolcs nem fog tudni
gondolkozni a chat gpt le tudja másolni
és egy hasonló szöveget tud írni de
valójában ezt nem fogja tudni pótolni az
én személyes jelenlétemet ugyanígy egy
személyes kapcsolatot nem fog tudni
pótolni a chat gpt-nek a helye az hogy
pótolja bennünk azt ami ami gépies ami
ismétlődő és emiatt fel fog erősíteni
bennünk mindent ami nem ismétlődő nem
gépes hanem emberi kreatív innovatív és
vibráló úgyhogy ezt a pozitív üzenetet
szerettem volna hátrahagyni nektek
számomra ez egy lelkesítő dolog sok
szempontból láttam ezt beigazolódni ezt
a gondolatot és remélem hogy a jövőben
ahogy haladunk előre a az ai chatbotok
fejlődésé v úgy egyre inkább ezt fogjuk
tapasztalni hogy az emberi oldalunk
felerősödik mert pótolja azt ami bennünk
gépi legyen egy szép napotok ha tetszett
ez a az összefoglaló kérlek adjatok egy
lájkot a videóra írjatok kommenteket és
iratkozzatok fel a csatornánkra szép
napot nektek ha tetszett ez a műsor
akkor iratkozz fel kérlek a csatornánkra
ezzel tudsz támogatni minket köszönjük a
vckker kávéközösségnek a jó kávéért az
ötvösudvarnak a helyért valamint a
bizalomtőkének a támogatás nékületek nem
jöhetett volna ez létre